[Music]
we love doing things that supposedly
can't be done which is why we couldn't
resist this challenge when something is
so difficult it's practically impossible
we say it's like catching lightning in a
bottle it's a reference to Ben
Franklin's kite experiment in which he
attempted to catch lightning and store
it in a Leyden jar he failed because you
can't catch lightning in a bottle right
maybe for our experiment we'll be
generating a charge of two million volts
using something called a March generator
[Music]
exactly how much energy is two million
volts
so we know how to generate the light
Hank but how do we catch it we decided
to try using super capacitors a
technology that was pioneered by GE
these are designed to release energy
very quickly so we use them for
high-powered medical scanners like MRIs
which require sudden bursts of
electricity importantly for our
experiment they can also absorb sudden
surges of energy although two million
volts is quite a surge
to prove that we've actually captured
the power of the lightning in the super
capacitors we're going to attempt to use
our bottle to start a car
[Music]